これじゃあ遊び社長ネスというわけでドイツいるんですけど皆さん高速道路って知って
ますでしょうか
多分日本の高速道路だとリーダーを出しても法定速度は確か初10 k とかだと思う
んですよ
ですが統一の高速道路には速度6低減の高速道路があるんですよ
ドイツにあるアウトバーンて高速道路がある
ですけどもなあと版っていうところは速度無制限道路としても有名でありますで全部の
国が速度無制限だけじゃなくて一定の区域が速度無制限
つまり何キロでも出していいんですよもう俺は日本のチンケな髪急なんですけどじゃあ
止まらねえっ角度5に入るんで広報的に車の出せ
スピード馬どこまで出せるのか体感してみようじゃねーかということで今日は
あと場で
本気で車で走ってみようと思いますスピード dasd スピード出すぞと言っても僕
別に国際免許とか持ってきてるわけでもないので僕は運転できないんで
この時のために最強のドライバーそして最強の車を寸日しました
ガーッ
wh
[音楽]
何のルイージで
ame
[音楽]
ん
やってますねはいというわけでアウトバーンを全曲たくするためにプロドライバーの
ペンとランボルギーニ準備しました
レーシング言ってたみたいですねあうん
pee
ん three hundred へ320キロぐらいまでは出るみたいです3
ベッテル所なんて本当に乗ったこともないんでちょっと米は推薦アウトバーンで300
球以上にたしてみようと思います宜しくお願いします
きっぽい
失礼します大
人来た来たそうとりあえずアウトバーの近くまで行きますでよろしくお願いします
かっこいい便かっこいいなぁ
まずは即
メーターはここに見えるっぽいですねー
5分
すごいよ ios てありーのーなるんですけど木塀
5レビュー
me big
[音楽]
ん
[拍手]
me
ブービー uno が半分だったよ
[音楽]
me
mar
持っていん
ああああああああ
がんばっ ni
宝積経だったんですけど今度は3月期のとか出ればいいなあとは思います
me
yeah
[音楽]
me
teame
me あった
ni
nore 1 en あいやー
2発で突いていない ana